ich habe bereits vor einiger zeit auf
einem kanal eine unterwasser challenge
hochgeladen und sich jetzt mal hallo
sagen kann das ist super und es wird
gesagt ich solle zuerst begrüßen von der
hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem neuen video von mir
und jetzt zu beginn was ich ja schon
gesagt habe ich dann halt und juli sind
auch da ich habe bereits letzten sommer
ein video hochgeladen in dem ich eine
unterwasser challenge gemacht habe
und da habe ich mir jetzt gedacht zur
feier des tages einen supertollen
vollpfosten hier ich habe mir gedacht
dass ich einfach mal unter wasser gehe
in einem wasserbecken auch tool genannt
wird
zur info weil sie sind das nicht geht
[Gelächter]
ich bin zehn mal untergetaucht und habe
bei jedem untertauchen ein anderes lied
versucht zu singen unter wasser und es
war sehr sehr schwierig ich werde nun
jule und sarah diese zehn videos
abspielen und sie dürfen dann nach dem
anschauen dieses videos einen tipp
abgeben welches lied ich eventuell
gezogen habe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
okay was im moment im moment ihr dürft
es doch nicht sagen ihr dürft ruhig
sagen wir haben nun das erste video
gesehen meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren deswegen würde ich sagen 31 das
erste video gegen jetzt relativ schnell
und relativ gut ich würde auch sagen es
war das einfachste von allen
vielleicht hat jude ist ja diesmal
achtet noch mal genau auf die ersten
worte die ich sagen sagt sei kein wert
nein das genau auf die ersten worte die
ich sage es euch noch ein letztes mal an
nein was nein keine ahnung
soll ich euch das gibt nochmal hier vor
sich ok dann machen wir jetzt zuerst
erlebt
humbaur sind titel und sicherte den
etablierten
[Musik]
es steht 2 1 für sarah aber vielleicht
ich habe er das nächste mal den
richtigen tipp geben es ist von einer
youtube
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es steht 3 1 für sarah das heißt wir
kommen nun zum nächsten lied noch mal
für euch personen spaßig werden
das finde ich damit ich finde weil ich
halt wirklich keine niederlagen
[Musik]
das nächste lied meine damen und herren
muss ich sagen ist hart schwierig ich
glaube dass hier keiner erwarten alles
hat gar keine reaktion
[Musik]
ich würde auch sagen am anfang wenn man
es wirklich erraten welche tipps zu
geben das hat etwas zu tun mit der post
schicken mir ein
[Musik]
bei der nächsten ich glaube ich das echt
hart einfach sein wird also lied nummer
60 watt ein paar achtet auf die ersten
drei filmen zusammengesetzt zu einem
wort ich keine ahnung ich gebe euch den
interpreten ok und wer dann das erst als
erstes den den lead namen sagt happ
geworden louis von sie richtig warum
klappt schon die mit mir deine jetzt
wirst du kannst es passierte von louis
formen sie jetzt weiß ich jetzt noch mal
das lied an
es steht 4 3
[Musik]
juli noch gefasst wertung was man daraus
sein könnte danke für deine teilnahme
also ich kann mich ja wieder tipp geben
aber diese suite ist wirklich hart hart
schwierig es ist derzeit in den charts
glaube ich in den top ten das einzige
elektronische lied das ist und mit
elektronischer du ja alles wirklich wahr
ist
[Musik]
ja es ist ihr wissen wirklich nicht wie
schwierig ist es unter wasser irgendwas
dazu sehen aber steht viel zu viel
ich möchte ich das glück
[Musik]
das ist die trolle will mein bestes
schon nah dran also der interpret ist
haftbefehl soll sich auflösen lässt die
applaus und so bist du hast genau genau
[Musik]
ich hätte ehrlich gesagt ich habe kein
einziges von mint nein es ist auch nicht
deutsch ist amerikanisch das mal genauer
hin so wie die tonhöhen sind soll ich
euch den interpreten sagen nee ich sage
euch einen tipp es war unglaublich lange
zeit in den charts auf platz eins
[Musik]
soll ich mal mitsingen haben falkenhaus
wird und bin ich
ja endlich auf 524 mio der sache du
kannst nur noch ausgleichen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt ein lied meine damen und
herren ich kündige erst jetzt schon mal
so ein bisschen an es ist auch schon
lange zeit in den charts das ist doch
gar nicht so alt und wir haben es heute
und gestern auch noch gehört das sagen
wir nicht das darf man sich jule hat das
problem schnell wieder durch verstand
ich würde sagen das ist ein faires runde
entschieden
ich hätte das auch ich habe den ganzen
tag gesungen sarah aber direkt so und du
hast dann eine sekunde später samt
werden und haben gesagt nicht gerade
regnet aber ihr könnt euch ja noch das
ganze video anschauen
[Musik]
an der stelle wird dass deutschland wie
das ist auch bei hätten meine damen und
herren
dank an euch zwei fürs mitmachen ihr
habt euch nicht so gut geschlagen wie
ich gedacht hätte wir haben hier
wirklich ein ausgeglichenes 525 ein
schönes unentschieden freude was habt
ihr von den liedern erraten durch das
ganze wenn es nur noch mal machen lasst
mal leicht schreibt man die kommentare
was wir erwarten konnten mit ihrer sagen
dass ich sehr unfair den schwierigen das
stimmt nicht
du hast einen rufnamen einmal vergessen
haben ich hatte geworden
du hättest nicht gewonnen nein ganz kann
hätte ich als allererstes